worries this morning of a potential
domestic travel ban
reports the biden administration is
considering restrictions
between states due to the new outbreaks
of the highly contagious
new strains of coven 19. joining me
right now is the governor of the state
many people have been flocking to
governor ron desantis of florida
governor it's great to have you this
morning thanks very much for being here
good morning florida has been the number
one destination
currently searched on the travel zoo
website what would a travel ban
domestically mean for florida
well one it would be unconstitutional it
would be a political attack against
florida if you look maria right now
you hear this debate over schools
florida schools have been open the whole
school year
we have every parent in florida has the
right to send their
child to in-person instruction every
worker
has a right to work and earn a living
and put food on their table and every
business
has a right to operate and consequently
our state is doing very well
uh compared to these other states in
terms of education and economy but
we also have 26 other states in the
district of columbia that have higher
per capita coveted mortality than we do
we have 28 states that have higher per
capita
cases than we do for the bulk of the
pandemic and if you look right now
states that are always held up by people
in biden's administration like new york
have way higher per capita patients
hospitalized for covid right now
so there's no basis in medical there's
no basis
in economics there's no basis in reality
to do this
except to punish a state that is doing
it better
than what his experts have recommended
biden is a lockdowner
his advisors are lockdowners lockdowns
don't work
we've demonstrated that we're not
turning back maria
and they will not be able to get away
with targeting florida
florida has been open for several months
and you have prioritized seniors
you have prioritized ensuring that kids
are in school
assess the situation in florida over the
last year
i know home construction is up home
sales are up
economic growth how is florida doing
well as you can imagine march april when
everything was was grinding to a halt i
mean we had a lot of problems like
anyone particularly because tourism
stopped
but since then we now have an
unemployment rate that is significantly
less than the national average
we had 25 percent increase in home sales
year over year 2019 to 2020. if you look
at the top 25
places where new home construction is
taking place at the highest levels
a plurality of those are in florida i
think we have six or seven
of the communities the number one place
in the country for new home construction
by far
is the village's retirement community
which has thrived during the pandemic
even though of course
seniors are more vulnerable to covet
than the bulk of the population
so we have a lot of great trends and i
would also say maria you have lockdown
states that are putting people
out of business we focused on lifting
people up but by doing that
you actually have new entrepreneurs
coming to start
new ventures new restaurants are opening
in florida new hotels are opening in
florida
and so people view florida as a place
where they can follow their dreams
it is a free state we are doing a lot to
focus on protecting elderly people from
covet
we're we vaccinated i think about 1.75
million seniors so far
about 40 percent of all seniors in
florida have gotten a shot
we're doing it every day continuing
until we get all the seniors who want a
shot
get a shot so there's a whole bunch of
things we've been doing for kovid but at
the same time
you know we've lifted our state up we've
saved our economy
and i think we're going to be first out
of the gate once we're able to put covet
behind our country
what about this concern about the new
strains nearly 350 cases of the
contagious covet variant have been
reported
in florida governor how do you read that
is there a reason for
for concern here so first of all well we
obviously look at all the data comes in
but but there
this strain is in blue states and they
don't talk about doing anything
with blue states we do a lot of of
analysis and genetic analysis
on strains so we find more than probably
some other states do but here's the
thing
since the beginning of january visits to
the emergency departments for covid like
illness in florida is down over 60
percent
cases are down hospital census is down
30 to 40 percent and so you've seen a
decline in covet in florida
uh and our winter high was much less
than the summer high but you've seen a
decline all over the country and so it'd
be very
odd to do a draconian travel restriction
which has no basis in the constitution
at a time when all of these indicators
are going down
and we really believe by focusing on
seniors first for vaccinations
we're going to be creating a protective
shield for a vulnerable population
so that if the season changes and you
start to see uh
virus increase anywhere that our
vulnerable population will be protected
at the end of the day that's really what
matters
if you're not really vulnerable to this
then that's not as significant as
somebody who has comorbidities or is
very elderly and so we're trying to
focus our resources where the risk is
and i think that's the appropriate way
to do it
right you've been adapting to this we
have to live with it
i want to take a short break but i want
to get your take on where this is going
and your expectations also
your push santas as we look ahead on
sunday morning futures we'll be right
back
we are back with florida governor ron
desantis governor we are talking about
the potential for
a domestic ban on travel and some people
are
saying this is a contradiction to what
we've been hearing from president biden
because of his open border policy
they're now talking about screening
domestic travelers but the new york
times has reported
that illegals are not being screened for
covid at the texas border
your reaction to these executive orders
of course they're not being screened for
covet at the southern border because
this is all political
so he's opening the border he's letting
illegals pour in
they're not doing any covid tests
they're just coming into the communities
we have no idea
what type of covet or other things that
may be carrying but yet
he wants to potentially make you take a
test
if you just get on an airplane and fly
from one american city to the next
or he wants to prevent travel to the
state of florida
this stinks to high heaven it is a huge
contradiction
and you can't square wanting open
opening borders for illegal aliens
but then also restricting u.s citizens
from basically traveling around the
country as they see fit and i think
the american people see the hypocrisy in
that
well look you've said from the beginning
that you want to prioritize
where the hurt is hitting most and that
is seniors
what is your reaction to the story
unfolding in new york
we will talk with congressman lee zeldin
coming up congressman from new york but
your reaction to governor cuomo
uh his aide admitting that new york
actually hid the data
hid the uh the data of the number of uh
deaths in nursing homes due to covet
well i think that that was something
that people knew months ago i mean the
media
just had different narratives you know
they've actually accused florida of
doing things with data without any
evidence
for that and there's been no evidence
it's come to light with respect to
florida but i will say
one of the most important decisions that
all the governors had to made at the
outset of this
is how do you how do you treat the
nursing homes there are a lot of people
saying
you needed to get nursing home patients
out of hospitals send them back to
nursing homes that you could clear
hospital beds
in florida we did the opposite we said
you cannot discharge back to a nursing
home because we were worried that it
would spread in the nursing home and you
would have
more deaths in the nursing home for
these vulnerable seniors and i said
i think we're going to have enough
hospital space but if we don't i will
build a field hospitals all over the
state of florida before
i throw our elderly people to the wolves
and so we were very strong on that
i think that was the right decision and
i think it's been borne out to be the
case as well
well you know you also have this uh
distribution
debate happening this week president
biden said that president trump
did not do his job on covet vaccination
programs
who is really to blame for the rollout
issues i know that
florida has become the number one state
per capita
for actual doses being administered
so look the the warp speed did a great
job and
this is a very difficult situation when
you have this amount of logistics
and i can tell you we wish we've had
more vaccine every week but this is just
being produced and so as the production
increases
you'll get more but every time they had
a shipment
from the middle of december until the
present it's shown up
where it was supposed to be so i think
by and large the warp speed team did a
great job
now if we get more pfizer if we get more
modern if we get to johnson and johnson
we're going to be able to scale this up
even further so we're hoping that that's
happening
so what i would say is stop blaming your
predecessor
stop playing politics let's work
together to figure out
how we increase the number of doses
available and we can get those shots in
the arms i'll tell you florida and other
states have done a good job
the hospitals their machines down here
now we have other test sites
drive-through sites
we have them in retail pharmacies and
supermarkets and in walmart
and so you have a big infrastructure
available
if you increase the doses available to
the states you're going to get even more
shots and arms
governor let me let me ask you you are
now on the front lines
many people say it's the states that are
on the front lines in terms of pushing
back on these executive orders coming
out of the biden administration
we know what the ag of texas is doing
suing the administration to
stop the deportation freeze and we know
a bit about what you're doing pushing
back on big tech
talk to us about florida's fight against
big tech the conservative
cancel culture that we were talking
about in the first
segment with congressman jim jordan and
alan dershowitz
what can florida state legislature do to
hold
big tech accountable what are your plans
i think we could do a lot one we can
support floridian's data privacy
maria if you buy a phone you think you
paid the money you have the phone and
that's the end of it
they are constantly pulling data off
your phone they're selling it
they make hundreds of billions of
dollars a year on that
consumers should have the right to opt
out of that and they shouldn't have
their data taken
uh without their consent we also don't
want big tech interfering in our
elections whether that means
deplatforming a candidate
like they did to president trump or
whether they're suppressing
information like they did with the
hunter biden story
so we want our elections in florida to
be free from that and we have penalties
if big tech tries to meddle
and then de-platforming and censorship
they
put themselves out as these open
platforms and they have always
these terms of service they're always
changing them they don't apply it
uh fairly across the political spectrum
that
for us is considered we think a consumer
fraud so we're authorizing suits
under our consumer fraud statute to be
able for
individual floridians to bring against
big tech if they get censored the
platform
and our state attorney general to do it
as well
so they need to be held accountable they
have way
way too much power they're not using it
in a way that is constructive for our
society
so i think florida's leading i think
we've had a lot of interest from other
states
there's going to see a lot of other
states i think follow florida's lead
you do need to do some of the things
federally like you talked with jimmy
jordan about in the previous segment
whether that's anti-trust or section 230
but there is a lot the states can do
and we're going to continue to pursue
that in the state of florida
you you are also pursuing something
along the lines of the rule of law when
it
as it relates to rioting right you had
mentioned that the last time we spoke
you were going to do something this
upcoming march
yeah so the legislature meets march 2nd
and we're going to have the strongest
anti-looting and anti-rioting
legislation in the country
it's going to apply regardless of why
you're rioting i don't care which team
you're on
we're going to stand for the rule of law
in the state of florida but if you are
doing things like
looting if you're assaulting cops if
you're doing all these things that we
saw
over the summer in many cities in the
country in florida you're going to jail
for that
we are not going to tolerate it and we
look forward to passing that and i think
it will be good for the state
governor it's good to see you this
morning thanks very much we'll be
following up
and we will see you soon florida
governor ron desantis thank you